[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
physician I first met linen Smitty
during the early part of Lynn's
pregnancy
I asked them if I could record some of
their experiences and show them to you
well we're finally here after nine
months of waiting and expecting and
empty by classes
and this is a labor contraction that I
am having Smitty and I are breathing and
relaxing over this labor contraction
giving me a feeling of control and
relaxation and I'm concentrating on what
we're doing
I think it's very important that the
husband that when he's a labor coaching
his uh his wife or Enterprise's labor
coaching with his wife that he breathes
with her and that way out like the way I
felt that I could stay right in time
with her and keep the whole thing
regulated and just feel like we're both
in control of contraction instead of
just her
I'm feeling really good like I'm having
a rather strong contraction at this
point but the contraction is not having
me you know hollering and screaming or
climbing up the walls I'm in control of
the contraction and actually I'm
enjoying myself as you can see at the
end of the contraction I'll break out in
a large smile which wasn't posed at all
but that's how I really felt very good
wow it seemed like a long time ago as I
think back on it uh going to the clinic
every so often as I recall the first
place that you stopped at when you came
to the clinic was the weigh-in here
nurse weighed you and compared your
weight to your previous weight from your
previous visit and this is the best way
of keeping you eating right not too much
and wrong Foods or what have you
after the weigh-in you come to an
examining room which can be very
frightening if you've never been in one
before however what takes place and
there's extremely important to you
because
when they do the internal examination
they take a pap smear for cervical
cancer and they also take a gonorrhea
smear to see if you have clamps they
also take blood samples to test for
sickle cell anemia if you're black and
also syphilis for every person if you
relax like they tell you to makes the
examination go much easier
uh another person whom you'll see from
time to time is the nurse coordinator uh
she helps you along with problems that
you might have questions that you might
have about your pregnancy about labor
and delivery and she prepares you for
the final event another service is
Family Planning and this is available to
anyone who wants to space their children
the Family Planning counselor describes
the different methods of birth control
such as coils diaphragms Foams jellies
pills Etc also abortion is available for
anyone who desires one
another person whom you'll see at some
point in your pregnancy is a social
worker and she can help you out with any
type with financial problems or problems
with your home situation such as
acquiring a babysitter when you're
hospitalized or something like that
she's a very helpful person and also
they have social workers that speak
Spanish for our Spanish-speaking
patients
a very important person
is the anesthesiologist and this is a
doctor who counsels you in the various
forms of analgesia and anesthesia that
is used during labor and delivery Smitty
and I had decided to go by so-called
natural childbirth another person whom
you'll see from time to time during your
clinic visit depending on how you eat as
a dietitian she helps you with any
dietary problems such as if you put on a
salt tree or sugar-free diet she can go
within with eating patterns and help you
uh stay within the restrictions of your
diet I saw her a number of times
uh however it's very comforting to know
that these exist
considering all the services available
uh I myself was very much relieved to
find out that uh she was you know being
well taken care of right here it's about
uh four o'clock in the morning and um we
have been here for about four hours
I just talked to the doctor and he told
me that uh uh she was four centimeters
dilated and that everything was going
along pretty good
what I'm doing is that I'm still uh
breathing with her and Counting with her
in order to maintain that control over
the contractions
also what I'm doing is I'm talking to
her to find out if I'm going too fast or
if I'm going too slow
and um uh this helps in this constant
dialogue between us this helps us to uh
stay in control over the contractions
oh I am so tired we've been going at
this for such a long time and even
though I'm lying in the bed I'm working
pretty hard but I really feel so good to
relax after the contraction and the ice
chips are really nice for a nice dry
mouth
uh it's nice that labor isn't just all
one contraction that is contraction and
a rest and a contraction and a rest and
in between like during the recipes and
just be yourself because you don't feel
anything and it's really hip to have
somebody with you to talk to you know in
those rest periods we would call you
know like a lot of places that uh
we went to in the hospital
and it was hard to believe that uh it
seemed like it was such a long time ago
that we have went on a tour here's media
and I on a tour of the inpatient
facilities and we're looking into the
Intensive Care nursery and this Nursery
is available for infants that are sick
and need special care it's really nice
to know it's available
patient room uh it was clean but it was
it looked to me like it was kind of uh
fair but the main objective to me was
that it was clean and that she would be
comfortable here I really don't like the
idea of uh if I was waiting for him but
I recognized that uh Sometimes some
parts join a labor that is necessary to
get away and rest and regroup your
thoughts a little bit and I was also
relieved to know that there was a doctor
that I could talk to uh in the father's
waiting room too uh reassure me of
things going along pretty good and there
was no complications or anything
in the delivery room which is a nice
part of the tour it sort of like the
examining room which can be frightening
if you've never seen one before however
the nurse explains the equipment and
what have you so that uh you'll be very
confident when you're brought in when
you're actually ready to deliver the
baby and it's very comforting to know
that the equipment there is to help you
and the baby
the recovery room is just what it says
recovery room after you've done a
night's work or a day's work uh you're
brought in here
to recover and also the nursing
Personnel checks your Vital Signs every
15 minutes to make sure that nothing's
going wrong and that you're recovering
it's about six o'clock in the morning
and Smitty's giving me a piece of hard
candy to keep my strength up and I put
it in my mouth but you'll see in a
second that the contraction starts and
that does away with the candy
the contractions now are pretty powerful
uh
pretty strong but we're still very much
in control and we're still doing the
same type of breathing
Smitty's really helping me along making
me comfortable helping me to concentrate
on the breathing and relaxation giving
me ice chips and hard candy in between
contractions arranging pillows and
everything
and you see the communication that's
between us
uh with between the eyes and what have
you it was really hip
here I belch in the middle of the
contraction and we really thought it was
funny so as you can see these were
really really powerful contractions but
we were still able to laugh and be
ourselves in the middle of them this is
the benefit of learning how to breathe
correctly and relax correctly
the contraction is coming to a close
pretty soon and as you can see by my
breathing it's like coming down the side
of the hill and it really feels good and
I keep feeling like this is another
contraction towards having my baby it
contracts themselves on a picnic but
during each contraction after each
contraction I really feel well I really
feel that Smitty and I have really
accomplished something really feels good
oh that felt good
and now I reward myself with a piece of
candy
it's about 8 15 in the morning and um
contractions are really rough
um we're in the stage what you call the
transition now so we had to change our
breathing pattern
but uh we still have uh uh still a whole
lot of control over over our
contractions
I was that was a rugged contraction I
mean there's no two ways about it I I
felt like the contraction was almost up
over me however we're still in control
and Smitty was extremely important to me
at this time because it was only by his
strength and his labor coaching that
kept me in control of the contraction I
was hot I was fiercely hot I was cranky
I even took the nurse's hand when she
placed it on my stomach and threw it off
of me I threw my clothes off of me and
everything
one of the things I remember uh most
about this contraction was that uh when
she first started getting cranky and uh
it was almost to a point of uh
driving me up the wall about it but I
recognize this is a part where she was
where we reckon that we didn't have too
much longer to go and this was the most
important part so um
we changed our breathing patterns and
still had control over our contractions
this uh
the only way I could really get through
this stage laborers not only by baby
Smitty's coaching but also by the fact
that the baby wasn't too far off this is
the hardest stage of labor but it's also
the shortest stage
this is really a rough contraction I'm
starting to lose control I'm forgetting
about how I'm supposed to breathe and
relax but watch Smitty how he just like
holds my eyes and gets me into the uh
correct breathing relaxation because
that was the only way that I was going
to control the contraction if it wasn't
for him I would have just climbed up the
walls and screamed and yelled and at
this point I started getting uh from
constant breathing with us I was
starting to do what you call
hyperventilated but um I still kept on
breathing because I was concerned about
trying to keep her having control over
those contractions
we have finally made it to a delivery
room and um I had notified the doctor
that uh she was feeling the urge to push
and on the route to the delivery room I
don't remember somebody giving me a hat
and a mask
all I remember was that I was wind up in
a delivery room and what I'm doing here
is uh holding her up and um pushing with
her
and I just feeling I felt that I was uh
at one point delivering the baby myself
Smitty was counting for me so I'd know
how long to hold my breath and even
though my face is all screwed up and it
looks like I'm in intense pain I wasn't
feeling any pain whatsoever all I was
was just working real hard and the
doctor was down at the foot at the table
catching the baby as it was coming out
but I was pushing I've never worked so
hard on all my life but it just felt so
good because this is the biggest urge
that I've ever felt and I wasn't feeling
any pain and I was just working so hard
like you can see all the sweat rolling
down from my face and my face is turning
bright red and it's because I was
working so hard and right there the
baby's head is crowning and that's why
I'm looking sort of shocked because it
felt weird one of the things that um
amazed me about this was that cleared up
any dots that I might have had was that
uh during uh between the pushes that we
was I saw that she was able to relax and
wasn't feeling uh any kind of pain or
what have you and just cleared me way
any doubt that I had about the you know
the whole procedure
the doctor right there as you can see
he's waiting for the baby to emerge
and um he was really giving us very good
support like the doctors really
tremendous I mean he played his part in
the whole experience very well and here
I am pushing again and I can feel the
baby coming out and I'm really excited
and I feel real strong sense of
satisfaction that I'm achieving
something it was really the most hip
thing I've really experienced and
Smitty's really helping me
and here she is
and I'm relaxing
and now I see the baby I say oh my baby
right now even though you can't see the
baby the doctor is suctioning out her
nasal passages to help her breathe and
she's really beautiful I can see her
down at the foot of the table and she
might be all slimy and a little bloody
but
you know she just looks so beautiful to
me and Smitty's so wound up in what I'm
doing that
he's not even he's not even looking down
at the other end
I was at this point that um even though
I was trying to be cool about it
um I just felt a whole lot of joy and I
started though
making attempts like to uh try to kiss
Lynn or even trying to even firmly with
my uh mask until somebody uh got the
bright idea and told me to take my mask
off then they told me to put it back on
but um it just at this point I just felt
a whole lot of uh joy and excitement and
I just was beside myself
I'm not a real gushy person but I just
couldn't contain it all there I was just
hollering and screaming because I was
just so excited that you know here's my
baby and Smitty and I had actually
worked together uh to push her in there
I just touched my baby for the first
time my doctor was so kind and uh held
around to me so I could touch her and
here's a big reward for what we've done
we were just ecstatic I just couldn't
control myself
and I'm just screaming
I just felt so good I've just never felt
so good in all my life
and
Smitty experienced the whole thing with
me I just you know I any other babies
that I have all want to have in this
exact same way
and here she is
Erica
uh in this scene we're trying to
breastfeed the baby and well it's rather
fumbly the nurse was helping
well at this point um
I had a feeling that uh there was
nothing more that I could do and I
didn't like that feeling so I just
thought I had to do something so I even
uh made an attempt to try to
help Lynn feed the baby even though I
couldn't actually feed it baby but I
tried made an attempt to try to uh help
her feed the baby I wanted to take uh my
part in that
it was really sweet all three of us here
together uh Smitty myself and Erica for
the first time
and here he is he's trying to
get my breasts in her mouth we're really
having a little problem there but uh it
was really cute
and here we are again uh being still
trying to get the baby to eat
he wanted to suck it was just my problem
of getting the rest in her mouth right
uh takes a little practice
but all in all we were all really happy
and here's Smitty helping again
and the nurse is helping too
here's Erica 10 weeks old and all
dressed up for our debut in the motion
picture world
and I'm trying to get her to smile but
all in all
what we really wanted to do we had such
a tremendous experience that we wanted
to bring it to you and show you how
childbirth can really be a hip thing you
know if you really work together at it
and there she is the end result
so now let's sit down and talk about
this